any
any give you the last chance here your
book
low life low life do i have to have to
trade a secret for selling
a book any last untold stories you have
for us
to share any crazy last untold stories
you have for us
just think about it like you have a
bunch of grandkids let you say they're
watching right now they're sitting there
saying
grandpa papa daddy you know you don't
give me one last story
the tyson mcnealy thing is okay i'll
give you guys give me one more moment
i'll give you i'll give you one fight
fight that didn't happen but but it's
worth calling
tyson is in prison okay so
and tyson can't fight i know ted
everyone knows heisen can't fight he was
he no i'll give you a little backstory
too he's put in prison deliberately
because he's dissipating remember he's
the biggest money fighter in the world
but he's falling apart what year is this
this is
whenever just after he lost to uh
to douglas so this is like starts in the
late 80s so
he gets convicted on a rape charge king
does everything he can
to keep him on just the opposite
just the opposite he needs to put him on
ice
he's falling apart so he's going to
implode
what's the best thing you can do take
him out of circulation
and he becomes the hottest property in
the world
right all and it doesn't matter who he
fights when he gets out
but he can't fight anymore that's
important to know
so i've got a guy named mitch blood
green
who fought tyson once on the street and
once in the ring
i said al braveman and they hate each
other
i say to al bray for men how about
mitch green he goes you know he's crazy
i said
i got something for you can you get him
in
to the into the facility where tyson is
being kept he said you know i can get
him in i said just get him in
just get him in he says why what are you
going to do people are going to want to
know what mitch green has to say to mike
tyson
since there are mortal enemies because i
can get him in he said what's he going
to say to mike heisen i said it's not
going to say anything to mike tyson
what's he going to do he's going to nail
mike tyson
he's going to hit him with the best shot
he can think of
and when tyson gets out who's the fight
that everyone's going to want to see
and you've got a safe opponent and i've
got
i've just made a million dollars
so why didn't it happen
because mitch green says to me how much
he making
i said i don't know you were making a
million dollars
he going to get more than me you know
i'm trying to say i don't i don't know
i said yeah so knock him out and then
you'll make more than he does and he
says
i ain't doing nothing to promote that
guy
and i couldn't get him to do it why
didn't he want to promote that guy he
hates him
yeah just because of that just because
all the money in the world he wouldn't a
million dollars
we're both broke a million dollars
and i said tyson can't fight anymore
just get through the first few rounds
and he's
i can see it you know he's going to
implode and then you'll be the
heavyweight champ and
my guy she has no business being the
heavyweight champ but you know
things are what they are and tyson i can
see doesn't want to fight
so that's it's kind of a boxing story so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye